عادت اصوات البائعين الى ناحيه جنديرس
المنكوبه لتملا احيائها المدمره بضجيج
الاسواق الشعبيه التي اعتاد الاهالي على
زيارتها لشراء البضائع بسعر اقل من تلك
التي تعرض في المحل التجاريه خصوصا ان
اغلب اهالي المنطقه عانوا من كارثه
الزلزال المدمر الذي اثر سلبا على القدره
الشرائيه لديهم بعد زلزال وضع تعبان السوق
كان قبل كويس هون سوق شعبي يعني قبل كان
كويس ماشي حال تجي العالم وتروح هلا ما في
حدا يعني نصف ندير استعاره بره يعني انا
جاي اترى بدي ابسط بدي اشتغل بدي استمر
بالحياه الحياه تستمر يعني ما راح توقف
الحياه
اسمع يصير ما راح توقف تستمر الحياه
مستمره
يشكو الاهالي هنا من ارتفاع الاسعار مما
دفع اغلبهم للاكتفاء بشراء المواد
الغذائيه الاساسيه وتجاهل اصوات بائعي
باقي البضائع ويعزو الاهالي ذلك بسبب
الكارثه التي حلت بهم والاضرار التي لحقت
بممتلكاتهم ما في قدره شرائيه غير على
الخضره كما العام عم تشتغل وتشتري خضره
تماما فقط لا غير بالنسبه للالبسه والباله
والجديد شغله ضعيف ما في ما في عندنا
الناس قدره ما في عندها قدره شرائيه يعني
عايشه اول باول اغراض غاليه وين بدي اجيب
وين بدي اجيب
في رحمه الله عنا يحاول السوريون العوده
للحياه رغم ضعف الامكانيات خصوصا بعد
كارثه الزلزال الذي تسبب بفقدان الكثير من
الاهالي لممتلكاتهم واعمالهم مما ادى
لتراجع الحركه الاقت صاديه في عموم
المنطقه احيت اصوات الباعه وضجيج
المتسوقين الامل في المناطق التي ضربها
الزلزال في شمال غرب سوريا
ليشوبها ارتفاع الاسعار وعدم قدره الاهالي
على شراء كافه احتياجاتهم خصوصا ان اغلبهم
فقد منزله وعمله وبات يعيش في خيمه قماشيه
محمد الاشقر العربيه شمال سوريا